on est déçu parce qu'on voulait aller au
vote on voulait aller au vote on voulait
que que la représentation nationale
puisse s'exprimer et que chacun aussi
prenne ses responsabilités parce que si
nous au modem nous pensons que cette
réforme est difficile nous pensons aussi
qu'elle était nécessaire pour les
équilibres financiers et pour la
pérennité du régime par répartition
aujourd'hui notre régime paraît
partition il est financé par les enfants
des travailleurs et ça ne marchera pas
longtemps et donc ça aurait été bien que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités que
les républicains prennent leur
responsabilité et que tout le monde
puisse voter le choix était différent
nous nous sommes dans la majorité donc
nous sommes un peu vous savez le système
du 49-3 nous nous coince mais moi je
suis particulièrement déçu de ce choix
il pourrait y aller il pourrait y avoir
plusieurs notions de censure
François Bayrou commentera enfin je le
commentera quand il le commentera c'est
tout
j'en veux énormément en républicain
parce que ceux à quoi on vient d'as
[Musique]
on est très mécontent du 49-3 on sait
pourquoi le gouvernement était obligé de
le faire par l'irresponsabilités totales
du groupe LR qui n'a pas su assumer ses
choix des choix qu'il porte depuis plus
de 15 ans depuis plus de 15 ans et
soi-disant pour le bien des gens et des
travailleurs et pour sauver le référent
la réforme des retraites et aujourd'hui
il se défile ça c'est grave pour nos
démocratie pour de simples calculs
politiciens donc ces gens là c'est pas
la peine de passer des accords avec eux
ils ne pensent qu'à sauver leur cul
pardon
[Musique]
tout l'aboutissement d'une
irresponsabilité totale des députés
voilà
mais le chaos
arrêté arrêtez de faire comme si vous ne
saviez pas pourquoi il y a le chaos
depuis 2017 depuis depuis
2017 depuis 2017 il y a le chaos dans
cette assemblée puisque le groupe la
France insoumise dès l'instant ils ont
les pieds au palais gourmands c'était
pour mettre le chaos il n'arrête pas de
parler de démocratie et de débat il
n'arrête pas de poser l'émotion de rejet
sur chaque texte sur chaque texte alors
ils veulent débattre où ils veulent
rejeter donc ils veulent pas débattre
ils veulent simplement que le peuple de
France accepte leurs conditions à eux
leur démocratie c'est comme ça les
chante eux et c'est eux ce qu'ils
veulent mais d'où ils sont démocrates
ces gens-là comment Emmanuel Bompard
a-t-il été désigné je dois vous le
rappeler il a été lu par qui il a été
désigné par Jean-Luc Mélenchon non non
mais oui comme député mais à la tête de
LFI elle est où la démocratie et ils
n'ont deux 16 de contester les votes
démocratiques d'ailleurs je vous
rappelle qu'ils ont perdu trois fois
pour parler de cette réforme
et se termine dans le chaos terminé mais
qu'est-ce que c'est dommage
mais une réforme comme celle qui a été
portée et forcément une réforme
difficile vous ne pouvez pas dire aux
Français de but en blanc on va vous
retarder l'âge de départ à la retraite
de deux ans sans que ça provoque des
remous il est évident noté que les
remous ont été beaucoup moins forts
qu'en 2019 sur une réforme de la
retraite par point qui était vachement
plus équitable que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui donc ça a quand même un
drôle de paradoxe mais c'est en
responsabilité qu'on a porté cette
réforme parce qu'on sait que le régime
paraît partition sans financement il
tombe par terre donc ce sont mes enfants
mes petits-enfants mes arrières
petits-enfants qui n'auront pas de
retraite si on fait rien et c'était tout
le combat des républicains depuis des
années et des années et là
ils ont une petite marche à franchir et
il a franchissent pas et ben qu'ils
aillent expliquer ça à leurs électeurs